and so I checked my phone and there's a
message a group message that says
do we need to get crisis management
involved and I'm thinking oh God here we
go again like somebody's overreacting
and so
um you know I'm like what what are we
talking about here so somebody then
sends a link to the video and uh so I
start watching the video I'm like I've
already seen five of these from the same
guy like okay here we go again who was
the guy that you're talking about Derek
from more plates more dates has made
quite a few videos right gotcha and so
I'm all negative about you
you know I wouldn't even call them
negative I I would call them the truth
well you know there is one that's
totally full of [ __ ] it's about me
having AB implants and ab itching like
so I I will say that's completely not
true
um but uh
so so I'm like okay big deal here's
another video same guy right and then uh
so I say you know tell me exactly what
minute to go to so then I went to the
minute that they told me to go to and
then they start reading the email that I
sent and I said holy [ __ ] like I did
this